what's up everybody it is your local
chat GPT sexbot Enthusiast Sam crankman
freed coming back at you with another
video today we are going to be covering
partitioning you may be wondering why I
have a hat on indoors it's because the
Jew fro is coming back so obviously I've
got to cover it up for the sake of the
video so let's get into it so that I can
go to bed
all right my iPad just tried to get me
to upgrade to iOS 16 beta which I refuse
because I am no beta so let's get
started with our introduction to
partitioning so the way this is going to
work is let's imagine that you finally
get off your lazy ass and start a
startup here right this is the database
representing your startup and all of a
sudden by the good luck of God you now
have a ton of users here they are right
over here to the point that actually
your startups database is starting to
get clogged up maybe it's got hundreds
of terabytes maybe even more data on it
and eventually that becomes infeasible
for a single system so what do we have
to do well replication isn't going to
solve this because even if we did do
some sort of replication it wouldn't
actually allow us to kind of split up
our data set into many pieces the entire
data set would still have to be able to
fit on one note and when that's no
longer possible we need to resort to
partitioning also known as Chardon which
is basically taking our original data
set right here and breaking it up into
multiple little pieces Each of which can
be stored on individual database nodes
so how does partitioning work well
obviously we have to break up our data
but how can we do it if we just do it
randomly that's not a great idea because
we can randomly throw our keys
everywhere that we want but then how are
we going to know where to find them when
we need to read them back so obviously
we need to distribute our data a little
bit better than that let's go ahead and
talk about how we can do this so the
most obvious approach is going to be
range-based partitioning so let's
imagine a scenario where I'm storing a
bunch of people's names based on their
first name and how many dollars they
currently have on their wallet so an
easy way of doing this would be to
literally split up all of our partitions
over here on the left basically by the
letter of their first name and so all
the people whose name start with a
through C go on the left in this top
database node over here and then you
know D through F in the next One X
through Z and the last one didn't draw
out everything
so what is a pro of this approach well
it's pretty obvious in the sense that
when we have similar Keys they're going
to be on the same node and so if we want
to do something like a range query this
is going to give us really nice data
locality remember that all of these
partitions are going to be on physically
different computers or at least some of
them are likely to be unphysically
different computers and what that means
is that we have to read to multiple
places over the network which is going
to slow us down it's always optimal to
be able to read from just one database
node and similarly it's always optimal
to be able to write to just one database
node so that is a big Pro on the other
hand there is a big con present and that
is going to be hot spots so in reality
like I did with this example probably
not too many people have their first
names starting with x through Z at least
in America and so as you can see here
we've got zero entries in the X through
Z partition which effectively just
wastes compute for us on the other hand
in the a through C partition we've now
got five names and so what that means is
that the a through C partition is known
as a hotspot in the sense that not only
does it have more people writing to and
reading from it but is also going to
store significantly more data than the
emptier partitions and what that means
is that we might even have to further
partition this partition
so it would be great if we could shard
in a more intelligent way it's such that
we don't have to do this and out of this
complication arises hash ranged based
partitioning let me go ahead and scroll
okay so let's imagine that now instead
of um just sharding by the first letter
of your first name we have this kind of
arbitrary sharding at the bottom here on
our left you can see their values from 1
to 250 251 to 500 501 to 750 and 751 to
a thousand so let's imagine that the
reason we're doing this is because we
have a hash function which takes in a
string
and it is going to return us a number
from one to a thousand and so what we're
going to do to actually figure out where
to put a given key and value is we are
going to take the hash of the key so
let's imagine we have Jordan is equal to
10. we're going to take the hash of it
let's say that spits out 821 and then
we'll find the node that corresponds to
that hash range so in that case 821 is
between 751 100 hence why we put Jordan
equals 10 over there
so what are the pros of this setup well
the whole reason that we did this in the
first place was to get rid of hot spots
and technically speaking this does work
pretty well with that if it's a good
hash function it should distribute the
keys relatively evenly around our hash
range on the other hand of course
nothing is perfect right if I were to
say you know let's say I was running
Instagram and I was trying to basically
hash all of our posts based on the post
ID but then all of the comments were
stored with each post ID if I were
Cristiano Ronaldo and all these women
wanted to uh hit on me from my post and
we're all commenting on it then we are
going to have a ton of comments on one
post and we may have to actually even
reshard those so again even hash range
partitioning isn't perfect for avoiding
hot spots if certain keys are just
extremely active and then what is the
con well again the main Pro of range
based practitioning was that we get good
range queries and in the case of hash
based partitioning we don't really so
what can we do to possibly Rectify in
that situation well we could use a
secondary index
so we've spoken about secondary indexes
a little bit in the past I believe at
least but the general gist is a
secondary index is an additional index
to your primary index it's a second copy
of the data effectively where you're
just storing it in a different sort
order so let's talk about two
possibilities of maintaining secondary
indexes in a partition database where
the first one is known as local
secondary indexes so the problem I'm
going to present to you guys is this
let's say we have a database of NBA
players and right now they're sharded on
their name let's just say it's a range
of the names or something like that
but in addition to that we also want to
be able to Shard on height and so that
is very important that we need to
basically store a second copy of the
data so in the case of a local secondary
index we basically take all of the data
on a given node and we would go ahead
and store a second copy of it on that
same node ordered in the manner that we
want so in the case of Shard one what
that would look like is I would reorder
it such that Mugsy comes first because
he's 5'3
then Alan would go second because he is
six feet and then jaw would come last
because he's six three and on Shard two
that secondary index would look like
D Aaron first
Vincent II
and LeBron third and of course these
would all be keyed by their height
so that is going to be the most
important thing there
so let's say I wanted to find all of the
people who were six three well it's very
useful that we have this Index right
because I can binary search on each node
and quickly find that you know we've got
jaw is 6'3 on Shard one but for me to
find all of our NBA players who are 6'3
I still have to read from every single
note and see that we've got a guy on
both nodes and the problem with that is
of course again that when you have to
read for many nodes things take longer
there are possibilities that that read
May Fail on one of the nodes and
ultimately there are just more points of
failure that we have to deal with
so that is definitely a big con on the
other hand the pro of this scenario is
that when you make a right you don't
have to do any extra work right all of
the additional work to create that
secondary index is maintained on one
single database node that is of course
in contrast with the global secondary
index quite a useful thing but also
quite precarious so let's talk about
that a bit so we're going to do here is
instead of maintaining a second copy of
the data on each node where all of the
rows are local to that node the global
secondary index is basically going to
take the entire index of all of the data
in our system regardless of what Shard
it's on and then effectively Shard that
so let's give an example so similar to
last example we are now going to create
a global secondary index of all those
NBA players so we might what we might do
is say Shard one is going to keep the
global secondary index of all players
that are 6'3 or yes
and so as you can see I have them all
right here and this would be stored in
addition to the original copy of data on
the other hand I could say that Shard 2
is going to maintain all of the players
who are 6'4 or greater
and of course again the whole point is
this is in addition to the data that's
already stored on there so keep in mind
that this stuff is still on Shard one
and this stuff is still on Shard too the
global secondary index is in addition to
that
and so now if we want to find all of the
players that are 6'3 it's only going to
take reading one note we just have to
read this guy right here and now we see
that D Aaron and jaw are both six foot
three
on the other hand there is a pretty
significant and major con here right so
let's say that I were to create another
six three player uh I don't know let's
call him Dwyane Wade
and he is going to go to that area of
the global secondary index but the issue
is that when Dwyane Wade actually gets
hashed we find that his hash function
for where he should actually be stored
in the primary index is over on shard 2.
and now all of a sudden we need to write
to one node for the primary index and a
second node for the secondary index not
only does that mean that rights are
actually going to take much longer but
it's very important that both of them go
through because what if this right
didn't work then all of a sudden our
secondary index and our primary index
are inconsistent with one another and
that is a state that we absolutely do
not want to be in so what does that
require
well if you're looking at the bottom of
the screen here you can see that is
going to require distributed
transactions and if we need distributed
transactions things are going to get a
lot more complicated so that is going to
be the topic of the next video anyways
guys I hope you enjoyed this one looking
forward to seeing you in the next one
and we will be talking about distributed
transactions and two-phase commit